hey guys this is andrew for trading
senses.com i've been working as a
professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and right now
guys i'm doing youtube videos
because i want to pass the knowledge i
want to show you guys how you can
make money on the markets all the
different tools and techniques that i
use that are working for me
and i want to show you how to do it
yourself so if you want to know about
all the stuff
you guys are in the right place so today
i want to make an update on rkt
rocket companies let's get into it
[Music]
so uh guys i did a video on a rocket
last week
so let's start with the daily timeframe
i was basically showing you
that i see huge breakout retested
and i think that we are gonna go higher
i think
once again that all the levels that are
around 20
25 are very good levels to buy i showed
you that
morgan stanley increased the target to
25
you know and it's not a surprise because
actually it's the level that
is now discussed everywhere guys so i
think that 25 is the
level to buy so i'm gonna give you some
targets so to find targets guys i use
fib extensions you can
watch my other videos i did a lot of
videos where i
show how to apply this method so
basically you measure the first wave so
let's go
back on the four hours time frame you
measure the first wave
so the first wave guys it's kind of
obvious here to find
you just take the low the lowest level
here the highest level here and you
apply this to the bottom of the second
wave one
two we are doing a three so for now the
three is weak so the three
has not really started yet i think it's
going to come
very soon let me just finish on the
targets so the targets
are usually the fib ratios so it can be
six open six one eight it can be the one
to one ratio or the 1.618 the most
common one is the 1.618
and guys i think that we are entering a
bubble so of course i'm very
bullish on all the stuff because the
bubble is actually
driven mostly by all the stuff that is
happening on reddit with gamestop
amc and even rocket i believe that the
1.618 is the next resistance level
so once again guys the the kind of trade
you can make is to buy
the re-test so the re-test is at 23 so
now we are at 25 so
should you buy here should you not guys
it's your it's your cold well let's say
you buy here
you stop loss let's put the stop loss
below the four hours 200 period moving
average so let's put it around 21
21.50 you can lose 12
how much you guys can make if you buy
here you can make 150
guys this is the kind of trade that is
very
nice to do don't put too much of course
if you want to take this kind of trade
but this is
very very nice trades on the hourly time
frame guys i just have something that is
not very nice electron lines trend lines
are very efficient in any type of market
so here if i connect the recent lows
one two three four reactions i can see
that uh so i'm publishing this video a
bit late guys i'm sorry because i do it
only
once a week so here i'm doing this video
on the 17th of march i have a breakout
of the 25 level so it's not confirmed
yet because you need to have two candles
and i have the 200 period moving average
and there will be time frame
it's coming here so i'm not saying we're
gonna go to 23
but even if we do guess this is good
news this is a better level to buy but
i'm just saying that this is showing a
bit
of weakness so maybe the rebound is not
going to come right away
but wait for it be ready once again guys
you have a lot of support
at this level so it's um
it's a very nice entry level to start a
long
position now let's check quickly the
short interest to have an update here
so i go on market watch guys and i cross
check my data with market bit
rkt short interest about 36 guys all
right
so 36 percent is a lot a short squeeze
might happen
and for the reasons i explained as well
on gme
guys you have some people that here are
selling call options once you have this
huge breakout the cool volatility is
very high and some people try to benefit
from it by selling it
so you have something that can happen as
well on top of the short squeeze is the
gamma squeeze
i think that all these effects combined
together might actually create the price
action to just blow up on the upside and
go to
my target which is 67 so that's it for
me i hope you enjoyed this video and if
you did please don't forget to click the
sub
like and bell button so you'll be the
first to know when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys